you're gonna want to listen to me this
is real and I have evidence to prove
what's going on here your episode
specifically is kind of a nod maybe a
reimagining of an original episode
what's the difference where I sit on the
seat it's the airplane I was a huge fan
of the original with William Shatner but
also the previous remake with John
Lithgow in the movie and grew up with
both of those so there was something
intimidating about stepping into this
but it was also quite different I think
the starting point is similar my
characters on a flight and starts it
thinks something is off in a really
specific way but no one else sees it
or hears it and kind of think he's crazy
or I think I'm crazy but from there it
goes in a completely different direction
than I will say this isn't the trailer
this is not a spoiler but we do see we
get a little nod to the gremlin did you
caught that yeah the original gremlin
from the William Shatner yeah it's
pretty cool
there are a few little Easter eggs like
that I think throughout the season a
bunch of cool things your next stop the
twilight zone what is an episode you
would recommend or episodes I would
recommend start with enough time at last
which is the burgess Meredith library
one time now a kind of stopwatch is a
really excellent episode something tells
me this is a very unusual watch the
dummy is really good if you watched
those like three episodes and you don't
like them then the twilight zone isn't
for you those are really kind of iconic
groundbreaking it will repeat itself do
you get
I'd saved us
[Music]
[Music]